[Music]
all right welcome everybody uh to this
tour of gspot.com I'm super happy to
have uh Jasper here with me to give you
guys insight into everything that we're
displaying right like this is mainly a
data visualization company we want you
guys to know exactly what the data is
that you're seeing um so yeah without
further Ado uh Jasper what are we
looking at right now where do you want
to start yeah thank you thank you John
I'm excited to go over all our old
features that we've revamped and all the
new stuff that uh we've built over the
past year so yeah it's pretty exciting
and I think we'll we'll ramp it up as we
go through this video right we're going
to start with the old stuff and then um
it'll get a little more complicated but
also a little more interesting as we go
through so for people that don't know um
what is it that we're looking at when we
when we see for instance like one of
these these two different green bars and
then let's look at the two different
types of red bars so let's just start
with this like really bright green one
over here for instance like what does
that mean yeah so these bars are uh
showing our gex or gam exposure by
strike and our brighter ones are gex by
volume meaning it's looking at the gex
of the volume of contracts that have
traded and then the darker bars are are
gex by oi or gex by open interest uh
which is just measuring the gex of the
open interest at each strike
yeah okay and then and then it also
seems like when I'm looking at one of
these there's also all these like really
cool dots as I hover over them I can
kind of see but it looks like 10 minute
prior 1 minute prior
1530 uh how are these calculated and
like how how would you go about using or
seeing them what do they mean yeah so
when we're looking at the bars we're
really just looking at the current state
um and so in order to get an idea of the
change across time uh we added these
dots where it's just telling you you
know five 15 30 minutes ago um what was
the level of gex at that strike um for
that time
frame gotcha so so if the dot is like
really far outside of the histogram like
maybe over here these like 4350 you can
see that the I guess the gamma exposure
there has been shrinking whereas if the
dot is inside the strike you can see
that the gamma exposure there has been
growing right yes exactly
exactly cool and then in addition to
that I kind of wanted to to mentioned
right like the a big part of the
challenge in designing a lot of these
tools has been the time component
because whenever you look at gex charts
uh almost anywhere like any of the
services that are out there um that you
know have done a lot to popularize this
stuff uh a lot of it's static which
means that um that that time Dimension
how things are changing over time which
is the main thing that we're thinking
about when we're looking at Price action
right just isn't included so between the
dots and this is you'll notice this is
kind of a segue um how does the like how
does this history slider work why is it
important um I'm talking about this
thing you can pop it out which is kind
of
fun yeah so our history slider is um
effectively of rewinding time so over
the course of the day as you know our
our state is being populated um if you
want to review say like maybe the open
or if you just loaded onto the site um
you wanted to see what was a last 30
minutes look like um Beyond just having
the dots uh you can then also uh pull
our slider back and review the change in
in the structure and see where people
were um coming into how they are
positioned
currently yeah and I think I think I
mean hopefully we speak for everybody
you know for for most Traders out there
when we say that uh being able to review
price action um and even honestly just
to learn how to use these tools I feel
like having the slider there to be able
to scrub through and say okay you know
this is how the day developed right um
is just super helpful especially with
something like gex where um it's it's
really um it takes a little bit of time
there's a little bit of a um how' you
put it there's a little bit of a of an
entry a barrier to entry before you
really get to a point where you feel
like you really understand and have a
get the hang for it yeah there's a
learning curve to it for sure because
it's not really a traditional way of
looking at
option structure um and you know there
is that initial barrier but I also feel
like uh to a certain point there there's
sort of an intuition that comes um it's
very similar to watching like footprint
charts or or order flow right where you
can get the feel of or watching tape um
where at first it's a little bit um hard
to understand but you kind of get a
sense of how buyers or sellers are are
behaving um and in that same sense
there's also that um or that similar
understanding that that can develop with
gex and how it morphs um how the
feedback loop occurs between uh spot
price moving through these positions and
positions reacting to spot price um the
reflexivity of it yeah and in that sense
even just having the history slider like
it's something that that we put a lot of
thought and effort into just because um
it can uh make your learning that much
faster right if uh instead of having to
spend hours and hours of screen time uh
you can literally just show up at the
end of the day slide through the day and
be like oh what happened today what were
the relevant levels how did everything
work um it's just such a it's honestly a
very powerful tool and and and I'm
emphasizing this because I feel like um
you know more people should do that I've
been doing it myself a lot actually um
but I should move
on yeah I mean I think reviewing trades
is very important this is this is a big
step towards um reviewing how how these
you know inter
too yeah and then and we'll get into it
more too in the in in the tools that
that that follow this uh before we move
on though um I wanted to go over uh
basically all the levels that we have
here on the right panel uh between from
zero gamma to you know Max change all
these things you want to do the volume
ones and maybe I'll do the open interest
ones yeah sure um so our majors and zero
are let's see
um so major positive uh and that's
marked in our dashboard it's also a it's
also charted on the plot itself um that
green mine um that's just indicating the
price at which um option holders or call
option holders are uh their positions
will undergo Max
convexity um and for major negative it's
the same for put holders and then zero
gamma is our neutral point between that
um between the
two yeah and then in terms of the open
interest levels it's the same idea right
um major positive is also that uh the
the correct me if I'm wrong but it's
just the call strike with the most
concentration of gamma at that point in
time right exactly and then the major
negative is the put strike with the
highest concentration um except that in
this case we're taking open interest uh
as our uh sort of the basis for that
calculation um the the volume ones in
day have a tendency to be a lot more ful
obviously because volume's live open
interest get got reported at the
beginning of the day and then didn't
change as much anymore but um then
moving into net gex on both of them both
volume and uh open interest is basically
taking the state of the entire chain
right so if we were going to sum up the
assuming that you know puts our negative
gamma and calls our positive gamma if we
were to take and sum everything up into
one calculation we have net gex and we
have a lot of sort of traders that use
that as a heuristic to sort of
understand what regime we're in
um and how much options are playing a
role in overall price action so uh you
know we're not going to get into that a
ton here but that's generally what it
means um the max change geks I feel like
are kind of underrated and are pretty
cool
uh just to have those there on the side
yeah so our Max change X is is also
another way of looking at uh the change
across time um so it's basically telling
you for each the those time frames uh
which strike underwent the greatest
change in gex um so you can it's a more
number
systematic uh more systematic um look at
uh uh what what strikes are getting hit
the most or you know whose positions are
are growing the
most yes yeah I think that's a good way
to put it right in general we try to
lean more into the visuals because we're
trying to create something that for
intraday trading that you can look at
and you know what's going on you don't
have to think about it too much right
that's the idea here um but you know for
people who do prefer something something
a little bit more systematic like
they're they're right like the numbers
are there right if you look for them if
you hover over you can find your numbers
um and you'll you guys will see that as
we move into the next packages uh one
thing I want to mention before we move
on is that even gex Spot Classic uh has
multiple tickers these are the tickers
offered right now and this will be carry
over through the other packages right
SPX spy QQQ Apple Tesla Microsoft Amazon
Nvidia um it's likely that we're I mean
it's basically certain that we're going
to continue adding tickers uh we're just
trying to prioritize tickers that have
high options volumes in which options
control a lot of the flows because we
want this information to be as
actionable as possible uh just also
quickly before we move on there's a
there's a pretty significant distinction
here between Phil full and next um
Jasper that full does the uh three
months of uh of xes right now or does
this do the entire chain yeah so full
does um three months aggregated gex so
we we look out uh and then within the
next three months we sum the GS across
those strikes and then next is just
looking at the only the next expiry and
so for SPX we have daily Z tods I'm sure
everyone's where that by now um but for
other tickers you know they might not
have zero tte so we're just looking at
the nearest expiration and that's why we
call it next as opposed to zero day and
then and then for instance like for
apple or Tesla or whatever um it's quite
likely that that's always going to be at
most uh what would that be like two days
away because it's Monday Wednesday
Friday every week anyway right yeah
generally yeah until they add zero DTS
on those two
huh God see then then we'll support that
too all right I I think we're ready to
move on the state yeah yeah Okay cool so
this is our next package and it's the
state package and the easiest way to
begin explaining this because it is a
whole different ball game is to begin
with the options
profile and actually let me load history
here so that we can show people exactly
what we're talking about but I'm going
to get into this a little bit because
this is sort of our our baby in a way uh
we um are very very fanatical about
orderflow uh classification and what we
mean by orderflow classification is um
we want to know whether when an options
order comes in whether it's a buy or a
sell right who is the aggressor in that
transaction um and so we uh you can get
into the documentation more if you're
interested in this but basically we use
a volatility surface model um to kind of
replicate the way that that market
makers think about the market and uh
classify orders as they come in and
we're talking about like we're we're
we're looking at a live feed that like
it's coming in um you know updated every
millisecond and and we're doing this on
the Fly which is what's really really
cool about this um and the way that
we've chosen to display all this stuff
is that um bars extending to the right
mean customer buys and bars extending to
the left mean customer sells and so
unlike a typical gex chart right where
uh in the classic one where there's this
Assumption of you know calls being
positive gamma and puts being negative
gamma we can actually distinguish um
whether on the day net net there have
been more buys or sells at that
particular strike for that particular
contract so in this particular case
right like the um and actually for all
these these charts I should mention you
can change the colors maybe we'll get
into that a little bit later um but uh
just for the purpos of explaining this
and with the default colors purple is
puts and uh orange or this this you know
lighter color um those are the calls uh
and so here for instance at 4435 you can
see that there's a lot of short calls um
here at 4,300 you can see that there are
a lot of long puts and
um this is basically a way to get a
sense live for um how people are
positioning themselves all the way
across the chain I kind of like to
describe it and I don't maybe you'll
have a better description of this Jasper
but I kind of think about it as our
landscape for the day how everybody is
um getting set up in the in the world of
options yeah it's a topological map
right of like where people are actually
positioned um one thing I want to note
too is that with this classification
model um the reason we implemented it um
or part of the reason really is that so
far our classic gbot um we're making the
Assumption uh where all puts are bought
and all calls are sold and therefore
there's you know the naive gex um still
works generally well uh but this is
really something that's only true for
SPX um due to the nature of the agents
who are actually trading SPX um now for
individual equities um generally that
assumption does not hold and so making
an assumption like that can really
distort what the actual landscape looks
like um of course you know we're
applying this classification to SPX as
well so generally we have found that
assumption to hold but um this is a way
of really pinning down exactly uh how
people are positioned and the way that
the way that I I like to think about it
and explain it to people is that um if
you're looking at naive right classic
gex gex by volume um high volume options
nodes are still going to be very
effective in terms of deter giving you
good levels to trade off of
uh it's not that right like that isn't
that isn't the issue the issue is um how
well does the gex model actually apply
in terms of determining Market Direction
um and whether you know we have seen on
occasion less often but sometimes there
are nodes that seem really relevant in
terms of classic gex that uh actually
all those orders are are matched meaning
that um even though there's a lot of
volume that level isn't necessarily
super important because um there's and
there is no disagreement about that
level everyone is very happy to transact
there um and it it doesn't it sort of
just um how would I put it uh there's no
outsize influence there uh because
everything's just getting carried over
uh quite nicely um that's more for sort
of like a trading video um while I'm on
that tangent I'll also mention for
instance right like here we've been
selling off today and you can see that
there's a ton of uh 43 45 short calls
around 6,000 7,000 of them according to
our classification system right now that
makes a lot of sense you know there's a
lot of call selling on SPX typically if
we sell off um because it's just a very
you know it's a pretty profitable way to
trade the index so as you get more
screen time with this stuff you start to
notice uh more things like this how
people trade options and I think it was
a you know it was a pretty big deal for
us too when we first made this and we
started to kind of see what was
underneath the classic gex model so to
speak like what was actually going on in
those in terms of um how the patterns
that we had Pro noticed prior were
actually being formed sort of with a
little more
granularity yeah I I think one of the
biggest things was like seeing stuff
come in um it's just like way more clear
in terms of where the actual imbalances
are um you know because it's it's the
market right there's there's a lot of
noise um and so generally it's about you
know making this is about cutting away
the noise and looking where people are
actually uh
located
yeah so here to reiterate right we're um
over as the day goes on we are uh
categorizing orders like basically
looking at time and sales categorizing
orders is either buys or sells and then
uh netting it out so if I look at the
strike I can say that net net there were
4,000 more Buys so far today of the 43
100 put then there were cells um it's
pretty simple uh obviously reading this
there's a lot of suby involved we still
have the dots we still have the replay
all that stuff um in fact that's one of
one one of my favorite things is to go
back and see how people were getting
positioned over the course of the day
yeah one important thing to note is that
um so for gex or gex profile um you know
for classic as well as the state package
we have both the full and next expiries
uh but for the option profile or the the
volume distribution uh we're only ever
looking at either z2d or the next expiry
um this is to really hone in the time
frame that we're looking at so we're
only concerned with the intraday basis
um you know for future updates or
features we'll probably add you know
further expiries in terms of looking at
classified volume but for now it's just
near term only yeah no thanks I totally
forgot to to mention that and then I
guess now moving on to next
um this is uh this is also only as with
option profile only looking at the next
xpre as we discussed before except here
what we're doing is a little bit
different because we're taking all of
the uh what we what we like to call
unmatched inventory or uh calls and
they're all getting displayed in green
and to the right and all puts are
getting displayed in red and to the left
and in terms of their gamma exposure
so um the reason to for doing this is uh
well number one it carries over very
nicely from classic because if you're
used to reading that then you'll have an
easier time reading this the other
reason is um what we're looking for here
are really more so liquidity zones and
so we don't necessarily care whether you
know it's a a customer or deal position
in particular we just care that there is
um open inventory there
um and and that that's a like that that
is a significant level uh and in
practice it actually and this has been
really really cool to see it actually
reads very similar to to a gex chart so
for instance uh the fact that we have
all these calls up here um is like
actually maybe I shouldn't get too deep
into that but yeah is anything you want
to add
jper um yeah I mean I still wanted to
kind of get into that right like you
know yes on our classified volume all
those calls are
short um and then but then here what is
it positive gex we're looking at but
really it's it's we're looking at call
geks right um but the actual functions
of whether those calls were long or
short um or the effect it has when spat
is trying to push through it is very
similar to to Classic gex right so we
have this wall um where it's it's sort
of a cap and it's not about whether um
someone's long or shorter but rather
this is essentially putting a a bit of a
lid um this is something that if we want
to you know Rally or we're kind of doing
a bit of a v um but if we wanted to
actually squeeze we would have to push
through this this large wall that that's
a really good way to put it so it's it's
sort of the um right in in terms of
analyzing whether participants want to
be long volatility short volatility how
levels are likely to behave in terms of
you know whether we're going to um stick
around there or whether they're going to
accelerate us stuff like that I think
the option profile can be very very
useful but in order to just get a sort
of a much cleaner picture um and just
understand where the liquidity is where
the big levels are how those levels are
changing whether volatility is making
them expand or contract um what the
Market's overall convexity is and what I
mean by that is um is there more of
opport to the upside or the downside in
terms of pure options being held
regardless of who they're held by that's
what this chart can tell you is that is
that a fair way to put it yeah it's
primarily concerned with levels right
it's kind of similar to seeing a lot of
absorption whether it's you know I'm
talking about footprinting again here
sorry but um you know if if there's some
large seller who's getting absorbing the
offer or someone slamming the bid at
some level we just know that it's a you
know it's a large liquidity level right
and and there's ways of um whether
you're trying to take a short or you're
trying to look for Price action to move
through that level um it's it's doesn't
matter whether they were hitting the bid
or the offer and that's the same as as
for the gex I was like really hyped to
see that some of our you know beta
testers when they first use this they
they hadn't even necessarily thought
about that like about the complexities
involved and you know what goes where
but they would just see the level pop up
really big and you see something like
this and you're like okay we're going to
43 45 you don't have to think about it
you just see the liquidity there you're
like okay cool you know um or you see
the liquidity getting you know you see
people getting out of these puts which
is what's happening right now and um
because you can see those dots are on
the outside and you can see that the
dots are on the inside here this strike
is growing and you have a really clear
idea of oh you know that gives me a
pretty clear directional bias I have a
very uh a very solid Target right yeah
liquidity is an attraction to to it
right it's like pulling price towards it
because that's where everyone's looking
it's reflexive in that sense and and I
think that that's something that again a
little bit of a tangent but that hasn't
been understood well enough in the gex
world it's that people are very
concerned all the time with whether
something is you know C like dealer side
or or paper side customer side but the
reality is like the market is a whole
organism the question is um where is
everybody positioned uh how is the whole
Market positioned and that's what we
need to know in order to know what sorts
of Dynamics are going to occur and so
that's part of the reason that we that
we did this the way that we did um let
me actually hop over into full because I
I personally love watching full um
because you can see yeah actually
yeah I don't know I like Max the most I
feel like it's the most like honed down
I mean that's that's totally fair I've
just been watching this the last few
days uh more and more and I just been
getting more into it so that the reason
I like it is because here as with
classic we're looking at uh the next
three months of X and we're running our
classification on all of that data right
and then it's all coming into here and
so I can see for instance on this
selloff if you look at next it looks
like there aren't that many puts
underneath us and I I like to see puts
underneath us in order to know whether
we're going to squeeze or not but if you
look at full you can see oh wow they
actually have been adding underneath us
uh because they've been adding in
further out exper so there actually is a
lot more juice under there to squeeze
um and then you can see it contract over
the course of the day and then I can
also go even further up and see oh how
far where are they adding calls right
and so it gives me an image that's not
just of today it's of how is everybody
reacting in the next three months of
xeres on the option chain because of
what's happening today although actually
there is a slight difference right in
terms of how we're doing major and minor
or or major positive and major negative
here or is it the
same uh no so so in this one we're only
doing Majors no zero um but the majors
are calculated the same as in classic so
we're just looking at like Max positive
or Max call convexity Max put convexity
um now the reason we're not doing zero
gamma um so we're still doing the sply
for this for um finding those Peaks uh
but we don't do zero gamma just
because uh so in classic because we're
doing that assumption there's almost
always well there's always that very um
clear gex curve if you can think of like
um you know drawing a line around the
put gamma and the call gamma there's
this sort of like X cubed looking uh
function and so there's a there's
generally a nice uh zero crossover point
which is our zero gamma um now for this
because the positions are rarely take
that like easy curve um we don't have a
good way of determining neutral at least
not yet I think we're still going to
look into that um but it gets kind of
funky when we're trying to plot Zero
game on on something like this just kind
of I mean I mean I I
personally don't mind it because it just
it essentially just reflects how much
more Dynamic the positioning is here yes
exactly and I think I think that uh gets
us pretty cleared up to move on I maybe
I should just let me just show you know
obviously as you switch tickers they
have different types of option chains
and so you see different types of things
I do really like watching spy on here as
well sometimes um but as we'll get into
in other videos right depending on the
ticker that you're
using um the the Dynamics are a little
bit different this is just about you
know visualizing the data classifying
orderflow getting everything up there so
that you have a really easy way of
understanding and seeing it um but U you
know spy SPX slightly different Dynamics
super interesting relationship though in
any case yeah let's let's move on to
order flow yeah so so now we have we
have time based charts um or this is a
way of looking at um over the course of
the entire day rather than just the
current ladder even with dots um this is
a more clearer way of looking the change
of um the option structure over time and
here we're essentially plotting um
across like the Deltas the gamas
something else called be call convexity
um and looking at the change over time
of uh how the positions are are moving I
know I think I think that's a great
primer let me actually I'm gonna move
back over here to uh options profile
right because and we'll stay on SPX for
the purposes of this right um because
the idea here is we have this like very
very powerful orderflow classification
algorithm um and it's telling us what's
coming in and what's going out all the
time but the problem is right when
you're looking at this uh as much work
as we've done to put all the dots on
here and have the history slider and all
that stuff and as easy as it is to see
these really big positions um what
happens if a massive order comes through
and you're looking away from your screen
and so it takes you a little bit because
you have to look back and see oh you
know the 4345 has been shrinking over
the last half hour or something like
that right like there's a difference
between looking at the whole position
looking at the landscape and actually
identifying what's happening in
orderflow um and that's what the
orderflow plots are for so we're going
to take all this stuff um all these uh
orders that are coming in and then we're
going to waight them according to either
their Deltas or their gamas so um among
other things which I'll get into as well
so if you look at Dex order flow for
instance what this is doing is it's
saying um we're making a very initial
sort of crucial distinction between what
we call bullish and bearish order flow
so bullish order flow means that either
somebody bought calls or sold puts
because those are both bullish and
bearish Order flow means that uh you
know it's the opposite either somebody
uh bought puts or they sold calls um and
then every time an order comes through
we're looking at the net Delta of that
order uh and then we're graphing it um
so bullish orders are represented by
bars going up and bearish orders are
represented by bars going down the cool
thing is we can do the same thing for
the gamma which which is how we get to
our gex order flow and gamma's a little
bit different because with Delta order
flow what happens is if there's a an
order like let's say that somebody buys
a ton of in the money calls right which
are an 80 Delta or something like that a
lot of times those are transactions that
are made in order to hedge other things
um and but it'll show up as a very very
big order on Delta order flow because
there's a lot of Deltas there gex order
flow prioritizes things that are at the
money or near the money so orders that
are coming in to seek maximum convexity
um in other words like they're taking a
very intense directional bet um and so
we wanted to include both so that you
know you can have your own way of
adjudicating what is significant and
what
isn't um and comparing the two can also
be particularly fruitful uh yeah yeah
one thing I wanted to note too is that
so when we're looking the lad right and
we're seeing the positions change um
often times you know maybe we see some
large strike um grow or Shrink um but
often times people are taking spreads
right they're you know they're selling a
put here they're buying a call there
it's a combination of of positions and
so with our subplots or order flow plots
um we're actually able to combine those
so rather than trying to look at the
ladder and trying to piece together
whether you know these positions are
being opened in tandem um you can look
at the order fot pots and be like okay
well you know the net Deltas of this
transaction occurring um is actually
this amount rather than trying to put
together
strikes um so then moving on to
convexity order flow that's something a
little different right um yeah that's a
little this is something that you know
we we discussed quite a bit um what's
the difference between gex and and
convexity or convexity really mean um
generally and this is kind of tied into
like the assumptions that are made of
about contract or options trading uh
with gex uh but gex is more of a
directional right so like we're looking
at calls and we're saying that they have
positive gamma um or puts and that they
have quote unquote negative gamma um but
in in actuality uh gamma is
totally uh it's not determined by
contract type um if you're if you buy a
call or you buy a put um you're long
Gamma or your your position has positive
gamma right it's not related to
Direction it's a bet on the expansion of
volatility right it's you're saying
something's crazy is going to happen so
I want to be holding on to something
that's going to pay me a lot if it
happens exactly yeah so like gex there's
a directionality baked into it but with
convexity we're saying okay well we're
just we just want to look at whether
people are long or short volatility and
you know because I know that like
selling calls inp puts is a pretty
common uh trade on SPX um and so
convexity is saying okay well you know
people are looking for price to either
stop trending or to continue trending
right so if they're shorting convexity
they're saying you know I don't expect
price to continue trending in its
direction um so I'm going to sell
convexity or sell gamma there um now if
I'm looking for a breakout maybe I'm
long convexity and maybe I'm looking for
a breakout that's so strong it doesn't
even matter that I can be long a call
and a put um so technically I'm
directionally uh unbiased um but I just
need the position to move or I need spot
to move enough so that my position will
will profit off that and that's sort of
the main distinction between convexity
and gex and I think there's actually a
really nice example here coincidentally
right which is that for instance we were
selling off right SPX came all the way
down here and if you look at Dex order
flow you see wow I mean there's a lot of
disagreement here it seems like but in
general it looks like well there's a lot
of bearish order flow here which you
know kind of makes sense because price
kept on coming down after that um but
then if you take a minute and you look
over here and you look at convexity
order flow you can tell that those were
positions that were short volatility
right because um the way that convexity
order flow is calculated is we're
basically taking uh as as as you put it
um long gamma goes up and short gamma
goes down so if they're buying options
then instead of having bullish bearish
if they're buying options then you'll
see these bars go up and if they're
selling options you'll see these bars go
down and here it looks like they
actually sold a lot of options so this
was actually a pretty major bet that oh
volatility is going to start to subside
um and that's more or less what happened
right we came down a little bit more but
that was more or less the end of the
selloff and so these can be really this
can be a very powerful indication in
tandem with these with Dex and gex uh
order flow to start to understand how it
is that people are getting positioned in
a particular product
at a given point in time we can move on
from here actually because it gets even
more fancy which is um for instance
let's actually start I think with the
aggregated decks because that to me is
the is the sort of simplest and
potentially even the most powerful
metric aggregate decks is probably the
most familiar to people who look at
these kinds of tools um we're
essentially just looking at uh the
cumulative State um over the course of
the day whether people are generally
bullish or bearish so in terms of like
purely how it's calculated like all all
we're doing all this chart is is if you
take the top chart and you imagine just
adding every bar up to the prior bar
whether you know positive or negative um
then that just produces the lower chart
so it'll just tell us over the course of
the day did people buy or sell more um
essentially you know share equivalent
worth of options on that day so you can
tell that so far today SPX has been
going down and people have been shorting
the market net net more using options
than getting along the
market yes
exactly yeah it's it's a nice little
sanity check and also if you see very
major divergences between uh aggregate
decks and you know spot price that can
be an indication that something strange
is
happening I think one thing to note too
is that you know when we're looking at
like the cumulative or or aggregate
decks over the course of the day um
we're looking at the change or or the
state right the cumulative State um you
can almost think of it as uh I think
this is more clear with like net
convexity or net gex um but it's almost
like pressure right there there's a
there's a measure of of pressure of
these positions that are occurring and
Order flow can also be thought of as as
a release of that pressure maybe there's
like a significant change in state and
orderflow is kind of marking those
points at which our aggregate decks are
um pivoting or or changing on a local
basis yeah and you can totally see it
right like for instance we have this
like really big order come through here
an aggregate deck drops right meaning
that you know somebody made a big
transaction they're shorting and then we
see you know spot continue to drop for a
bit um and yeah you know it's this one's
this one's pretty one to one um the the
other guys are a little more complicated
so I'm going to pull
up uh net gex over here and this one's
actually I mean I kind of love this one
today to be honest uh because so all all
net gex is doing is uh and we call it
net gex because it is net gex if you go
over to state right and then you you
take a look at uh next um and let's we
make sure SPX right here uh if we were
to take the
gamma right the gamma exposure of
everything right now and clearly right
now on SPX it's it's significantly more
call dominated than it was earlier in
the day because of this one specific
4345 strike so if we move over into the
orderflow
tab and we look at net gex over here you
can see it's been climbing and climbing
and climbing climbing and what that
tells us is that there is more upside
convexity than there is downside
convexity in the option Market at this
time so what we're doing is we're taking
call gamma exposure um and subtracting
put gamma exposure uh and that's and
we're taking the state of the entire
chain so that means that essentially
we're looking at this picture whatever
that picture is and then we're doing the
math on call gamma exposure minus put
gamma exposure and so you can tell
whether the market is in terms of like
pure you know uh upside versus downside
convexity extended more in One Direction
or the
so for instance this really big shift
right here I don't know do you see this
jper like at around 2
p.m yeah there's a big spike
there yeah it's just it's just we're in
this like really clean Trend where you
know people are getting they
essentially more puts are being bought
um uh or opened I should say more puts
are being opened open open open and then
all of a sudden we get a big shift and
that comes prior to the actual bottom of
the day but it looks like at least today
in terms of pure convexity you know the
option Market transitioned before uh
before SWOT which is kind of
interesting yeah that that change is
marking people looking for that
reversion especially after such a quick
sell off like that right people are
looking for that uh that little bounce
there yeah yeah which is you know um
either they sold a lot of puts or they
got into a lot of calls in this
particular case I know of how net gex
works that this means that all of a
sudden people started getting into a lot
more
calls um let's move on and then I think
we have only have one left which is net
convexity yeah so net convexity is is
similar to net gex and how we're
calculating it right but as opposed to
call versus puts we're measuring um the
state of positions that are long gamma
and subtracting positions that are short
gamma right so know as people are
looking for more convexity as that
builds over the day we can see that or
if they're looking for Less convexity um
a little more simply put um you know
increasing convexity is people looking
for that V expansion um and as we're
coming to a level or you know people are
measuring certain things they're
expecting less volatility or or
volatility to reverse um convexity
typically we'll see it drop
down yeah and and and the math behind it
and I love that explanation the the math
behind it is really just taking the
gamma exposure of long options and
subtracting the gamma exposure of short
options and so you can actually see that
transition here which is really cool uh
even before the selloff you can we
actually right at the beginning
convexity net convexity starts to build
build build until all of a sudden on SPX
net net we actually have positive
overall convexity exposure meaning that
option holders were expecting more
volatility we get a lot of it um we
remain positive up until this point and
this is where option sellers stop start
to step in and they start to sell more
options right and uh just barely but
we're still sort of zero and then here
right almost at 2m is when people really
start to sell more options and we get
this like big big big transition so
um when a lot of options are being sold
right um when we're at a level that is
all the way down here like this is quite
substantial risk off it means that you
know we're expecting volatility to
contract for the rest of the day um but
again right like that only really
started happening like let's say
whenever we broke this level which is
sort of our our like uh Baseline option
selling level for the day it looks like
that only really started to happen
around 2m which is around here right
yeah exactly so I mean we were really
lucky to get such a clear example today
but uh it's it's it's pretty amazing
just to see how
um
like the way that Traders expectations
of volatility um directly translate
right into you know whether they're
buying or selling options and from I
mean I I my background is more so as an
option Trader and this is something that
I really wanted to have because I want
to know um you know is it okay for me to
be holding on to to to to short you know
short strangles here or not right like
what's uh what's going on what do other
people think yeah it's a really great
bird's eye view of like what everyone's
trying to pile into what they're
expecting you know how they're reacting
to price you know following their
expectations or not and
yeah yeah super cool um and again you
know for all these things obviously that
you know we can switch between tickers
uh and you'll get different perspectives
because different Traders trade
different tickers uh and there's like
there there can be um you
know it's it's also part of you know
just getting to know your
particular uh your particular underlying
and and how it trades right everything
has its own character and hopefully
these tools are a good way to get to
know that character man well that's a
that's a lot of stuff Jess it
is I think we
covered everything
actually I think I think that that was
everything um I should mention right
like there's we have resources p uh
resources page with actual documentation
all the formulas everything thing um
um and and you know some pictures as
well and uh yeah I mean we're we're
around to to answer questions and and we
hope that um as many of you guys as
possible learn to use these things and
and figure out to use them in ways that
that we haven't even anticipated I mean
that would be absolutely wonderful yeah
thank you guys hope you guys have a good
one good luck with all your trading I
hope I hope our tools help you guys with
that that
too